36 people
have died in california because of fire
okay 36 people
uh the number right now in the state of
california
is 4.6 million
acres in california's on fire right now
ky if you can bring up the video
4.6 million acres that's a lot of acres
by the way you buy a house that's an
acre
you're sitting on a nice lot 4.6 million
acres
and specifically if you go to san
francisco's orange sky
okay just type in uh on youtube san
francisco orange sky go to youtube
sky fire uh
go to videos yeah that's what it looks
like but go to videos because the videos
kind of gives you go to the one that's
two minutes and 29 seconds go back
go back one go to the sky news one yeah
right there that one right there watch
the skyline of san francisco looking
more like an image from mars
the orange glow from wildfires miles
away
from the city's landmarks not that bad
blocking out the sun
the middle of the day felt like dusk and
it is
unnerving i was wondering what time it
was
and then i looked outside and it looked
like doomsday
i mean you could tell something is
horribly going wrong
and as far as going to work and
breathing
in all this this pollution is definitely
not intelligent guys
it feels like the end of the world it's
pretty scary look at this look what she
says
she's a die hard california lifelong
californian and
it makes me weak can i sell done to my
poor state
and those fires continue to rage across
the western united states
driven on by strong dry winds earning
more of california this year
than ever before watch this it's about
to get uh the next
part is more intense an unprecedented
number of fires destroying some
whole communities it is the speed with
which these fires spread
that's especially alarming
the people who lived in this
neighborhood had barely any time to
escape
sheriff's coming through going level
three get out
wow get out and uh yeah grab some papers
grab some papers and stuff this is it
this is what i've got
heartfelt man didn't make it out
deaths have been confirmed in a number
of states and officials say that number
will go up watch we can expect to see a
great deal of loss
uh as a result of these fires both in
terms of
structures and in terms of human lives
um
it as i mentioned earlier could be the
greatest loss
in human lives and property due to
wildfire can you stop the video
thank you so you know these fires that's
going on with california for somebody
that is from california tom
what do you got to say about it
devastating it's so heartbreaking it's
unbelievable those are human lives those
fires move
so fast there's nothing you can do what
are you gonna do get a couple tankers in
the air you can't stop them
uh you know i live in southern
california in manhattan beach
you look at the weather forecast no
clouds sunny it's dark
i mean it's not as bad as san francisco
but but it's it's everywhere i've got a
lot of experience with wildfires the the
woolsey fire in malibu a few years ago
uh my daughter went to pepper goes to
just graduated from pepperdine she had a
run for her life to get out of that
thing came over the canyon
uh unbelievable and i live in manhattan
beach which is about 27 miles away from
malibu i could see flames
when you look towards malibu that's how
intense these fires are but this is
unbelievable
the thing that's really upsetting is a
lot of people want to make this only a
climate issue
right but a lot of these fires are
man-made they're arsonists that are
starting these fires one guy was
arrested for starting seven of them
in oregon and these things people
arsonists are going out there
yes or like these maniacs are going out
there and starting these fires so
when you see you know that woman that
was talking and crying i mean
your life is they come through those
small towns so fast
and then they'll they'll they'll uh
encompass the city where there's no
exits
there was one town where they had to
airlift everybody out there last week so
it's unbelievable we just see the
headlines and we see the smoke and we
see the skyline with the with the orange
hue but man it's it's really really bad
i think the question is is it climate
change or is it
fires like is it does this have to do
with the climate or does this have to do
with california's not being responsible
and figuring out a way to solve this
why can't it be both why can't it be
both yeah so answer
so if you think it is climate change and
that's not what i said i think it's
both i think climate change things are
getting hotter
you know i think that is a factor but
arsonists
there's my my question i don't have a
major point because i don't unders being
in florida the worst thing that happens
is a freaking hurricane maybe in
september
california is insane with these fires
it's crazy my question is this
the entrepreneurial spirit in california
is crazy silicon valley crazy
billionaires tech companies things are
happening the cloud the software
why can't they figure this out why can't
something be done here
right forget about another social media
app forget about another freaking cloud
computing app figure out these [ __ ]
fires or you won't have a state anymore
california you know the climate does
have something to do with it when it
doesn't rain
everything's a tinder box so anyway
you're on the ocean
you're on the coast yeah but what's
happening in the central america
once you get it plus the land is so
expansive and then you get the trees
which is the kindling too
it's it's maybe worse in oregon so it's
the whole west coast i don't know if you
can put everything
correct it's not just california oregon
washington state i want to say
why why don't you why don't you put a
bonus together why don't you put a
incentive together for the first person
that does this we're going to be giving
xyz on the state of california
yes why don't you put an incentive
program so the one thing i do like i
like the fact that trump flew out and
had the meeting with governor newsom and
everybody in california one it shows
leadership from trump's standpoint too
it shows that newsom i mean what choice
does he have to say no to meet with him
but he
was willing to meet with him but now i'd
like to see that meeting take place
with musk i'd like to see that meeting
take place with the guys from google
i'd like to see that take place with
peter thiel i'd like to see that take
place with caltech i'd love to see that
with jack dorsey
i'd love to see a twitter campaign
coming out i'd like to see
a massive incentive being created
microsoft in seattle
everything on there somebody come up
with an incentive what kind of an
incentive could you do
everything is incentive driven how can
you not give the incentive to solve this
who's gonna fix this pat
is the government going to fix this or
entrepreneurs no it's going to be but
the entrepreneur must have an incentive
there needs to be a massive incentive
financial incentive
that's what entrepreneurs are driven by
it's either recognition or incentive
either make them be in the history books
we're doing something
like how do how do charities raise money
your name is going to be on this wall
you know your name's going to be on
legacy
yeah give them a legacy or give them
money give them one of those two things
that's what entrepreneurs
give them a percentage of what the state
doesn't spend on trying to put these
fires oh yeah
yeah it's here's the scary thing every
year it gets worse you know
2016 2017 this is happening and then we
had all those rains in 2016 and 2017
where you think this is done
yeah right we're not having to deal with
this anymore and just it gets worse
every year you think these lands burn
and they can't burn again but that's how
big california is
there's always more land to char but by
the way where is pelosi based out of
san francisco what has she said about
the phone oh she's been on the front
line she's like holding a hose
haven't you seen her she's driving a
helicopter air drops she's all over this
yeah she's all over this
her hair looks great though her hair
does look great so very impressive
a little blonde so there's homeless
homelessness problem going on in
california yeah
and now we got fire now we got cops
being shot
uh president trump has gone to emergency
meeting california i mean just what a
wonderful job that state is doing